it is one of the easiest and most
accurate ways to detect breast cancer an
annual mammogram recommended for every
woman over the age of 40. in today's
healthwatch denise joins us to tell us
about a fast track way to schedule this
important screening hi denise hi there
and you know when it comes to these
annual screenings chances are you need
to visit your primary care doctor then
they're going to give you that order
form you're going to take that order
form you're going to book your
appointment but that process can take
weeks maybe even longer the breast
center at sunrise hospital however wants
to eliminate that gap in time from when
a woman gets her annual mammogram to the
time she gets those results so this
location allows patients to make their
own appointment without needing needing
an order from a doctor a woman needs to
be 40 years or older and not be
experiencing any breast issues
they simply can come in and say i want
to suffer for a mammogram if they've
seen a physician within a year
that they will receive the results if
they didn't see efficient we can help
pick one for them
the breast center does have radiologists
on site who will check your scan give
you the results before you even leave
that office and that quick turnaround
really can go a long way to ease a
woman's fears so coming up tonight here
at six o'clock in our buddy check eight
report we're going to show the low-cost
or even freeway nevada women can get a
mammogram and it's thanks to the
generosity of a golden knights player
back to you christian